♪ ♪ ♪
ntntntntntntntntntntntntntntntn,
Éric Zemmour veut marquer
son entrée en scène.
Devant des milliers
de partisail annonce la création
de son mouvement politique.
ÉRIC ZEMMOUR, candidat élection
France, Parti "Reconquête!"
- No
de notre pays pour le retrouver.
(acclamations)
- Des cris et des
ap
d'un événement également marqué
par des épisodes tendus.
Des journalistes brièvement
mis à l'abri par la sécurité
et des affrontements entre
partisans et militan
antiracistes qui se sont invités
dans la salle.
de présenter ses priorités.
- Arrêter immédiatementemememems
semaines de mon mandat.
L'immigration zéro deviendra
un objectif clairererererererer.
(applaudissements)
- En martelant ses messages
sur l'immigration et l'identités
électeurs de l'extrême droite,
isisisis aussi ceux de la
droite traditionnelle.
du parti Les Républicains lance
ce message à ses partiuiuiuiui
pourraient être tentés d'appuyer
Éric Zemmour ou Marine Le Pen.
élection France Les Républicains
- Nul besoin d'êtrltltltltant
pour être convaincant.
Vous le savez, les marchands
dans l'action.
- De l'autre côté du spectre
politique, la gauche est ause e,
le parti socialiste et
les écologistes, mais
aussi la France insoumise
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon,mememememd
rassemblement électoral
dimanche.
JEAN-LUC MÉLENCHON, candidat
élection, Franceonononononononor
une grs s s s s de plus :
Non! La France, ce n'est pas
l'extrême droite! La France,
C'est la santé publique!
émémémémémancipation! C'est
l'école! C'est la recherche!
C'est le partage!
- À près de quatre mois
du premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle, gegegegege
politique est morcelé. C'est
sans compter plus au centre
Macron, dont la candidature
n'est toujours pas oe.e.e.e.e.e.
Un nombre élevé d'aspirants
présidents qui rend l'élection
imprévisible.
des recherches, Ipsos France
- Ça a un impact maje
que ça fait que mécaniquement,
la barre pour se qualifier
pour le deuxième
C'est-à-dire, que vous avez
la plupart... vo
qu'Emmanuel Macron qui est
à un niveau supérieur à 20 %.
Donc, beauco, , , , , , , , , ,i
une chance de me qualifier".
- En avrndndndndndndidats
devront aussi faire face
à un autre adversaire :
la tuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuius
de l'ampleur lors
s s s s s s élections.
Ici Raphaël Bouvier-Auclair,
Radio-Canada, Paris